mlb move in 2021 all-star game from
atlanta in response to georgia voting
law usa today story
major league baseball will move its
all-star game out of atlanta after the
state georgia passed
voting bills that will
disproportionately this is the story of
usa today
affect citizens of color and action that
commissioner rob manfred on friday said
is
the best way to demonstrate our values
as a sport mlb's removal of one of its
jewel events which this year will
include the draft for the first time
comes after a year
in which the covet 19 pandemic and the
killing of george floyd by minneapolis
police officer called caused the sports
industry to reconsider its influence
with its society on march 26 governor
georgia governor brian kemp signed
legislation
passed by both state house a republican
let over
overhaul of state elections rolling back
voting by mail and other absentee ballot
efforts
and even banning the distribution of
food and water to those
standing in line to vote which by the
way we're going to verify that
mlb did not specify to which city it
wrote relocate to alloster all-star game
which due to its fixed date
and loan spot on the sporting calendar
is its biggest corporate event of the
year tom give us your thoughts on this
i i think it's first of all i think it's
good
when you know we're all taking a stand
together as citizens
but you know this is this is very
political i mean there's a lot of small
businesses in georgia that may not
that are not on the left they're on the
right they're just here they're
independent and
now they're going to be hurt they were
expecting hotel rooms they were
expecting restaurants they were
expecting a lot of things they were
coming back for the summer and there's a
lot of small businessmen and people
in that local economy you're going to
get hurt and by the way where do you
draw the line and being upset
where do you draw the line on being
upset you know that
you know what happened with george floyd
and the things that we have to do and
the the improvements and the
all the additional ground that we have
to take
so that everybody's got a chance and all
these things are
you know less prevalent every new
generation that comes along
is very very important that importance
is not diminished
but you're there's a lot of business
people and there's a lot of things there
the georgia government does something
and but and
both houses and then everybody's upset
and now all these business folks get
hurt so i you know i'm
i'm bummed out about it but there's
things underneath that are very very
important
but i'm really bummed out that that the
political wave comes over like this and
it's going to hurt other people in the
process yeah i'm going to give a couple
different perspectives here it's so
funny because florida always gets a bad
name
for just everything and whether it's
politics whether it's
social whether it's everything makes
poor sports fans
and georgia's this past year is just
basically like hold my beard we got this
whether it was the elections for the
senate run and now this uh just a couple
different sides of the coin here so
you talked about the businesses being
hurt they said that a hundred million
dollars is going to be lost to the state
of georgia
100 million dollars by that so that's
the tax to georgia that's not the
underlying revenue to those little
companies say it again that's the tax to
georgia that's not the
that's not the underlying revenue for
everybody that sells hats
t-shirts you're saying it's bigger than
100 million
yeah the revenue to all the little
business people and stuff is much bigger
according to cnbc they lost 100 million
dollars that's but
did did you just catch what happened
right there like so when thomas saying
100 million is just to the state there's
going to be a lot more money that's
coming in through the
small business billions that's billions
it could be potentially a couple billion
yeah come with you on that
uh by the way it did get moved to denver
i don't know if you heard that yet which
totally makes sense okay
so obviously big blue state so
a couple different things here so if you
have brian camp the governor of georgia
who got completely
lampooned by trump all throughout the
senate race
he came out and he said this is
disgusting this is cancelled culture of
the highest hypocrisy this is ridiculous
like
let's keep politics that's what's
confusing about it what you just said
but continue
okay yeah um so keep sports out of
politics keep politics out of sports
and then you have uh companies like coke
delta uber lyft
paypal under armour estee lauder they
all pulled out of it and then obviously
when they start pulling out everyone
else starts pulling out of that but
something that has actually
manifested certainly during the pandemic
and certainly
during uh the blm movement social
justice movement is that
you know the whole lebron shut up and
dribble right so
sports stars and even ceos are no longer
just sticking to business they are now
putting their hands into social issues
and into politics and they're kind of
getting deeper involved
other than just sticking to business so
sports players aren't just shutting up
in dribble
business people aren't just following
following the business of focusing on
the money
they are taking a stand on social issues
and
whether you agree or disagree those are
sort of just two sides of the coin
um but sports business politics
whether you like it or not they're sort
of all intertwined
and this is sort of the culmination of
all that where
the mlb all-star game where you're just
like look it's an all-star game why are
we making this political yeah
it's now all a big show so here's
here's the thing
officially we only have one sport left
that has now been politicized
only one so now i thought baseball was
going to stay
you know neutral and independent now
there's only one sport out of the top
four sports that's no longer politicized
hockey hockey is the only one
nfl hardcore politicized well with all
the nba
hardcore nba is like far far far
they even have last names on their
jerseys it's just too much now now you
got mlb and then
lebron comes out and gives a shout out
and says hey great job mlb for standing
up so did obama so did a bunch of other
people
and they're claiming that what a biden
did in the interview with espn is
gaslighting because he went up then he
says
i want to applaud the mlb you know for
for standing up for themselves and
let's face it i mean you trying to say
this is like jim crow this is you you
can't even give people water
i mean what do you mean we can't even
give people water biting is saying that
you can't even get
water he said can't even give people a
bottle of water is what he's saying so
you can't go out there now
i went and said okay that's pathetic if
you can't even give the people that are
voting
only poll workers now let me tell you i
got the article and i got it from
washington post and heritage let me tell
you the difference
washington post hardcore left jeff bezos
heritage action conservative hardcore
right okay i'm going to give you both of
them
and you make the decision for yourself
okay so let's go through
washington post the article if you want
to pull it up so people can see the
title of it on washington post
expand access a historic restriction
question mark what the georgia voting
law
really does so go up a little bit to the
main one
so how does the law limit go all the way
up where it says how does the law there
you go how does the law limit voting
it shrinks the window of voters to
request mail ballots rather than
allowing voters to request mail balance
six months from election day the new law
says voters can start requesting ballot
78 days out okay so you lost 90 days
of asking for it counties can begin
sending ballots to voters
just 29 days before election rather than
previous
49 days it also sets an earlier cutoff
date for ballot
application requests critics say any
mail delays with these shorter periods
could lead to voter not getting ballots
on time or not being able to being able
to return there in time but proponents
of the law
say voters simply don't need the 180
days they used to have to request
ballots and that moving up the cutoff
date makes it less likely voters will
receive ballots too late
to get them back in time to be counted
okay you can make a decision say you
like it you don't like it but that's one
of them
next counties in the state can send mail
ballot applications only to voters who
request them as opposed to simply
sending every registered voter a ballot
application and cannot fill in
information ahead of time
next by the way if you guys got comments
comments as i'm going through no voter
id requirements
voters may who cast mail ballots will
have to provide
one of several forms of identification
this provision which replaces the
signature match previously used to
conform
confirm voter identities is one of the
most controversial because critics say
it's likely to disproportionately affect
black voters
do like what do you say about that town
the fact that you have to show an id
and they're saying it's it's it's not
fair to show id's
what do you say well what do you mean
there are several forms of them it's not
just a driver's license because maybe
your drivers are suspended maybe you
don't have it
there there's several forms of identity
yeah i can't comment on
anybody who's analyzed it and say it's
disproportionately going to affect
one group of voters or not but there was
several forms of identification there
was a list
yeah so again uh but that's one big
argument we'll come back
one of several forms have been and
anything you have identification to to
go in and get
health care at an emergency room coke
who supports this decision with mlb
if you want to go to the annual co
convention you have to show your id when
you go in
the level of hypocrisy on what people
are saying here's basic id for me to
know who you are it's not a big deal for
you to show your id
voters don't have to provide a copy of
identification but could example provide
a driver's license number social
security other acceptable
identification this is not a big deal
next a limit on the number of ballot
drop boxes during early voting it
essentially limits the number of
dropboxes in each county
to one per early voting site or one for
every 100
000 voters in the county whichever
number is smaller and the drop boxes
can't be conveniently spread over the
county for example in places where there
aren't
in-person early voting locations they
all have to be located either in the
county
election office or at an early voting
precinct location they have to be
indoors which critics say
make them less accessible and could lead
to crowds where voters are already
congregated tom you're shaking your head
that's ridiculous
because what they're saying here is
let's put the boxes in a place where we
can watch them and make sure
everything's cool
and by the way if this goes both ways
because
either party will be screaming about
this based on who won yesterday
you know that of course this this is
trying to put the boxes in a place
where we know where it is and the votes
can be counted properly
and we want to put it in a place where
it's less likely
you might we get a third yeah it's just
i think that's i think that's
really stretching and reaching they're
trying to say
here's the drop-off locations we're
going to put them here here and here
you know we're talking that's their
argument though that's washington post
argument let's go to the next one
shortened early voting and runoff
election instead of a minimum of three
weeks of early voting and runoffs early
voting and runoffs will be held in a
single monday through friday period
the next one state lawmakers get much
more power over county and local
elections and republicans have decisive
majorities in both states senate
and state house today today the law
states that the general assembly will
select the chair of the state elections
board rather than the board being
chaired by the georgia secretary of
state
an elected position the chair is
supposed to be nonpartisan the state
election board can investigate county
election board
and has the power to suspend county
election superintendents
though the law limits the state board to
suspending four at a time
you might remember georgia secretary of
state brad who became
the target of his own parties ire after
president donald trump asked him to find
votes in the wake of 2020 election this
provision seems like a direct reaction
to that ensuring
partisan state lawmakers can control the
elections process more directly let's
not forget kemp
did not do what trump asked him to do
and trump
couldn't stand what kemp did to him so
just
five months ago kemp was a good guy now
kemp's a bad guy
even though he didn't defend trump trump
was asking him to take it
take care of him and didn't happen next
a ban on handling handing out food and
water within 150 feet over here comes
the truth or within 25 feet of any voter
republicans say this is aimed at
stopping outside groups
from influencing voters democrats say
it's supposed to make it harder for
people to wait on long lines
particularly
on hot or cold days election officials
are permitting to set up water stations
but they're not required to do so we're
going to go into more details
on the one from heritage action because
they actually explain
what that really means that that means
i've sat
stood in line to vote for over an hour
and it was here in dallas and it was
warm day
and what this is you are not supposed to
be approached by
any person while you're waiting and
non-partisan can give you water
partisan cannot give you that's right so
if the league of women voters sets up a
water station there so i can get water
on the hot day
i can get water no one's depriving them
but what they're saying is
you know when you get out of your car
and they say excuse me are you voting
for this position or that position
but soon as you cross like where the
cones are they can't talk to you anymore
you're now in a polling place and no
one's supposed to be
within so many feet of you that's what
this is about this isn't about depriving
people water
we've got four minutes i want to go
through both of them a few ways to ex it
expands
voting a minimum number of drop boxes is
guaranteed kemp has been arguing
publicly
that in rural counties that didn't have
drop boxes in previous elections
this is an improvement drop boxes
weren't allowed in georgia at all
before 2020 and all counties had them
even during the pandemic world
while the number dropbox is so limited
it might not make a huge difference for
voters kemp is correct that the law for
the first time
codifies requirements for a minimum
number of drop boxes in each county
phenomenal that's very good keep going
up keep going up keep going up
now they're required there must be
drop-offs an additional day of early
voting in the rural counties the new
bill requires at least two saturdays of
early voting for each primary and
general election previous georgia law
required only one it allows
counties to choose when their early
voting locations are open for a minimum
of eight hours between
7am to 7pm reasonable more resources for
precincts so lines don't get too long
the law basically requires the state to
monitor polling locations to see if any
have lines longer than an hour or still
have voters waiting in line
for more than now after polls were
supposed to close in those cases the
state is required to either form
new precinct locations to ease the
strain or beef up the existing polling
locations
capacities to handle large number of
voters this applies specifically to
populist precincts
mostly in urban areas sounds like more
opportunities i agree as well here's
what didn't make it into the bill
a block on sunday voting earlier
proposals called for a ban on sunday
voting this proposal was seen as
directly targeting black voters who
often
vote as part of church run so the polls
effort that takes place
on sunday this is a good thing they can
still vote on sunday they can all take a
walk down together there's a good thing
yes a ban on no excuse absentee ballot
time just turn off your ringtone just
turn it off yeah
a ban on no excuse absentee voting
georgia republicans actually passed the
bill in the state senate a few weeks ago
that would have
banned no excuse absentee voting one of
the most criticized but on
not uh uniformly agreed upon jp personal
okay so so that's
washington post go to go to american
heritage go to
heritage action for america this one's
short it's just two pages
okay myth versus fact the georgia
election law okay myth number one the
georgia election law discourages voting
suppressors votes
fact the bill actually preserves or
expands ballot access in several
important ways it requires that large
precincts
with lines more than an hour take long
take uh hour long take steps like adding
voting machines an election personal for
the next election to reduce wait times
it does not change the number of total
early voting days actually increases the
mandatory days
of early weekend voting compared to 20
20 134 159 counties will offer more
early voting hours than future elections
under the new law it codifies election
okay we read that all right
voters can't continue to vote absentee
with no excuse unlike states like
delaware which who is from delaware by
the way
isn't a guy named joe from delaware i
think he's from joe biden's from
delaware
voters can continue to vote absentee
with no excuse unlike
delaware which is where joe biden's from
new york connecticut which required an
excuse
to vote absentee myth number two the
georgia law eliminates voting
on sunday to surpass african-american
votes georgia law was silent on sunday
early voting days prior to sb202
and in 2020 only 16 out of 159 counties
offered early voting on sundays the new
law
expires explicitly provides the option
of holding early voting on two sundays
for all locations it actually increases
the mandatory days of early
weekend voting across the state that's
myth number two number three
there's only six of these so hang tight
the georgia election law suppresses
the vote with a onerous onerous voter id
requirement the law requires a driver's
license
or a free state id number which 97
registered voters already have
anyone without valid id can easily
obtain one for free the voter id
requirement replaces the state's
controversial signature match program
that led to disqualification of
thousands of votes in 2020 the law's
voter id requirement for absentee ballot
is overwhelmingly popular in georgia
across the board according to
agc atlanta journal constitution the
newspaper in downtown atlanta
in january 74 percent of georgia voters
support it including 63 percent of black
voters and 89
of those making under 25 000 a year
interesting
so that data is not being written by
washington post
but now we know you can click on the
link agc to go to it not yourself sam
the audience if they want to do it not
us myth number four the bill
the bill eliminates drop boxes for
absentee voting fact the drop boxes used
in the last election did not exist a
year ago they were
first utilizing 2020 as a pandemic
precaution the bill makes them as an
official part of georgia elections and
they will be available 159 counties
and under supervision to protect against
tampering number five
the bill lets republicans throw out any
county votes they don't agree with
the by fact the bipartisan state
election board can do performance
reviews of local election supervisors
who failed their areas voters
with things like long lines and off of
absolute value the board will not
overturn election results the law simply
provides a process to review and
ensure officials are technically
competent and complying with the state
laws
the process requires a high burden of
proof someone said okay okay god and
then last but not least myth number six
the bill bans drinking water for voters
while waiting in line fact like the
countless other states that have very
specific laws against lh
electioneering near polling places
georgia has
codified rules preventing political
groups from handing out food or water to
voters in line
as an incentive to vote but specifically
allows poll workers to make water
available to anyone who wants it
the law will also directly cut down wait
time meaning refreshments for people
waiting in line
will be necessary this law didn't move
the all-star
two books right yeah i was going to say
this did not move the all-star game
joe biden gaslighted and moved the
all-star game
i mean that's what people are saying
that's the spectator and everybody and
by the way coke
and everybody else sees the world
reacting they want to be on the right
side of history so they say okay we're
out
because they don't want to explain that
something is misunderstood they're like
no i'm not going to get in the middle of
this if this is getting too hot then we
have to move and we have to be on the
right side of history
look even though this is really sad the
audience has the choice
to pick and choose which article they
want to read i give you both of them and
put the link below for people to go see
it if you can comment below as well can
you do that oh you want to put in the
description
put in the chat box right now so people
can go to it if they want to go to it
but here's the point yep what happened
over there was so politicized
right that atlanta you know braves took
a hit
small business owners took a hit major
hit fans
took a hit huge hit massive hit why
rob manfred already made a dumb decision
a couple years ago when the astros did
what they did and he didn't suspend
anybody
and he said if anybody hits them we're
going to suspend you none of the astros
players got any kind of punishment the
gm got fired or whatever happened to him
nothing happened there two years later a
year and a half later he was saved by
kovat everybody forget about what
happened to astros
okay right except from some fans that
are going on with trash you know at the
games
year and a half later he does it again
and he is going to bring back up the bad
decision he made with the astros but he
is using this as a way to win the
journalists and the commentators that
were trashing him just a year and a half
ago for the decision he made with the
astros
it's his way of winning some cool points
and uh he may win it
100 percent but he took a hit with the
league maybe wrong that's my thoughts
adam final thoughts yeah no
this is the beauty of listening to the
pbd podcast is that we're going to give
you both perspectives and you can do
your
own research to figure out what makes
the most sense and what the truth is but
we're going to kind of give you both
sides of the spectrum
and as they always say if you have two
different perspectives the troops
sometimes is
uh in the middle uh and so go do your
own research
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye